INTERESTED IN, EITHER.
>> Tucker: ANYONE EVER NOTICED
THE LIBERAL SNOWFLAKES -- FORGET
IT.
JOINING US NOW, MOLLIE HEMINGWAY
IS WITH US.
MONICA CROWLEY IS WITH US.
YOU KNOW YOU THINK BACK, I
SUPPORTED JOHN McCAIN WHEN HE
RAN FOR PRESIDENT WHEN IT
MATTERED.
BECAUSE I THOUGHT HE WOULD BE
THE BETTER PRESIDENT.
ALL THOSE PEOPLE THAT VICIOUSLY
ATTACKED HIM, IT WAS LIKE, THEY
WERE HIS BEST FRIEND.
WE SEE IT WITH GEORGE HERBERT
WALKER BUSH, AND IT'S NO LONGER
A POLITICAL THREAT.
YOU ARE THE GREATEST PERSON THAT
EVER LIVED.
>> YOU KNOW, DEATH ENHANCES THE
MEMORY OF ALMOST EVERYBODY.
IT'S PARTICULARLY STRIKING WHEN
A REPUBLICAN POLITICIAN OR
PRESIDENT PASSES AWAY, AND THEN
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA WHICH
RELENTLESSLY POUNDED THAT
REPUBLICAN POLITICIAN DURING HIS
OR HER TIME IN OFFICE, THEN
SUDDENLY, THEY ARE A SAINT.
I THINK IN THE CASE OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA WILL USE ANY CUDGEL TO TRY
TO POUND THE PRESIDENT INTO THE
GROUND.
WHEN SENATOR MCCAIN PASSED, THEY
CERTAINLY DID IT THEN AND ARE
DOING IT NOW.
I WROTE A COLUMN FOR SPECTATOR
USA TODAY TALKING ABOUT HOW
PRESIDENT NIXON ESSENTIALLY
LAUNCHED PRESIDENT BUSH INTO --
AS A NATIONAL FIGURE,
GEORGE H.W. BUSH RATHER AFTER
THEY LOST THE SENATE CAMPAIGN.
I THINK THAT LESSON, TOO, IS
THAT THIS POSITION -- AND
WHETHER IT'S RICHARD NIXON,
RONALD REAGAN, SENATOR MCCAIN,
GEORGE W. BUSH, BUT YOU SEE THAT
AS PLENTY WHEN THEY PASS AWAY.
>> Tucker: IT IS A BIT OF A
PHENOMENON.
AND THERE ARE THESE GUYS ON TALK
RADIO AND PEOPLE THAT SAY, -- I
WOULDN'T TAKE IT PERSONALLY.
THIS IS SO OVERWHELMINGLY
TRANSPARENT TO ME.
>> AND IT IS PARTICULARLY PHONY
IN THE CASE OF GEORGE H.W. BUSH.
THAT'S THE ISSUE WHERE THE ONLY
GOOD REPUBLICAN IS A REPUBLICAN
WHO IS NOT A THREAT.
THERE IS A PRETTY QUICK CHANGE
IN THE MEDIA COVERAGE FROM
GEORGE H.W. BUSH FROM WHEN HE
WAS PRESIDENT, AND THE MEDIA
COVERAGE WAS VICIOUS.
THAT WAS THE COVER OF "NEWSWEEK"
MAGAZINE.
TO SAY TODAY THAT HE WAS SO KIND
AND RESPECTABLE, THIS WAS THE
SAME MEDIA THAT WAS DECRYING HIM
FOR HIS PERSONAL TRAITS.
THEY LIED ABOUT HIM AND HIS
REACTION TO A SUPERMARKET
SCANNER WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" NOT ONLY
NEVER CORRECTED BUT REPEATED
JUST YESTERDAY.
HIS MEDIA COVERAGE WAS SO BAD
THAT HIS PRIMARY CAMPAIGN BUMPER
STICKER WHEN HE RAN FOR
REELECTION WAS, AND, IT'S NOT
OKAY.
IT WASN'T A LIFETIME OF SERVICE.
MY FATHER ALSO SIGNED UP AND
SERVED IN THE ME AS WELL.
WE LOOK AT THIS, AND IT'S LIKE
LITERALLY HEARING PEOPLE, THIS
IS THE DEATH OF A REALLY
HONORABLE HUMAN BEING.
HE IS A NICE ONE AND NOW THEY
WILL USE THAT TO BLUDGEON TRUMP
BECAUSE THEY DON'T LIKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I SPEAK AS A DEMOCRAT >> I WANT
TO SAY ONE OTHER THING THAT
ABOUT GEORGE H.W. BUSH THAT IS
BIPARTISAN AND TRANSCENDED IN
IMPORTANCE.
HE MORE THAN ANY SINGLE
INDIVIDUAL WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE FALL OF THE SOVIET UNION,
THE FALL OF THE WALL, THE END OF
COMMUNISM, IN EASTERN AND
CENTRAL EUROPE.
AND IF WE AS DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS CAN'T CELEBRATE THAT
NOW, THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG
WITH US AND I HOPE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS FOREIGN
POLICY HAS A SIMILAR SUCCESS.
>> I WOULD ARGUE REALLY QUICK,
MONICA, THE POLICIES OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON REGULATION
AND TAXES, ON JUSTICES AND
JUDGES ON THE COURTS, ON THE
WALL, EVEN, PEACE THROUGH
STRENGTH, STANDING UP TO OUR
ENEMIES AND IDENTIFY EVIL THAT'S
ONE OF THE REASON WHY THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND OTHERS WHO
OPPOSE PRESIDENT TRUMP OPPOSE
HIM.
AND IT'S A STRONGER MILITARY AND
STRONGER INTERNATIONAL POSITION
AND AMERICAN VOTERS AGREE WITH
THAT AND SUPPORTED.
>> SHOCKING, AND I WILL GIVE HER
THE LAST WORD, WE HAVE ABOUT 25
SECONDS.
EVERY PRESIDENT HAS THEIR OWN
STYLE AND SOMETIMES A MOMENT
CALLS FOR, LIKE I WOULD ARGUE
THIS ONE, DISRUPTIVE.
DONALD TRUMP BREAKS A FEW DISHES
BUT THINGS ARE GETTING DONE AND
WE NEEDED THEM TO GET DONE.
>> IT'S OKAY FOR DIFFERENT
PRESIDENTS TO HAVE DIFFERENT